two flats f and f prime that are
incomparable
in other words f is not included in f
prime and f prime is not included in
f so they're incomparable with respect
to conclusion relation
then the product of those two variables
equals zero
and then we have some linear relations
so for any ground
set element let's say i look at all the
flaps
containing high and then sum those up
and that needs to equal zero that's the
second relation
so that defines the charring of a matrix
now why is this important
so the key statement about
discharging of a metroid due to
alipacito
and cats
is that there's charring of a metroid
regardless of whether a matrix is
realizable or not
satisfies a good these
three set of really nice properties
usually satisfied by chromology rings of
smooth projective varieties
these are often abbreviated in this way
so the first property is poincare dual
quality
second one being hard left shits
third one being the hot stream
emulations
now i won't exactly say what these are
well point graduality i'm sure many of
you are familiar
really for law concavity properties
what's the most relevant is the hash
human relations
um especially in degree one
and what that states is that certain
matrices have
exact certain symmetric matrices have
exactly one positive eigenvalue
so that should sound quite familiar
already
from looking or from the definition of
laurentian polynomials
and so the property the hot treatment
relations is exactly
what allows for
applications to establish some lock
locking cavity results in combinatorics
so in our case so how was this
established the proof of
this theorem is through induction within
another induction so it's a nested
induction where intermediate objects
some of the intermediate objects are not
even made right
so it's a rather involved proof
and one way to cast
our work with spencer backman and conor
simpson
is okay can we establish these
properties
purely staying in the realm of
maintenance
and turns out with some new ideas
and combining this powerful tool called
laurence and polynomials it's possible
to do it with a single induction to
establish these properties that i just
laid out
that does not involve anything other
than matrix so it's just
an induction on rank at the end of the
day using
our new approach so how do we achieve
this
well the main observation to start off
is that these variable z's of f's
in the geometric sense
are not f so this triangle matrix does
represent a homology ring
for realizable matrix and geometrically
one can
observe that these variables in the old
sense are
far from that actually so we need some
new set of generators
for this showering if we want to apply
the laurentian polynomial we really need
to start with
some elements in degree one part of the
chao ring
that has property called neph
and that's what got us to define the
following
linear change of coordinates for this
character which we call the simplicial
presentation
so what's the simplicial presentation of
the child ring
let me just put this nabla underneath
just to
indicate that this is this implicit
presentation distinguishing it from
the usual
so this is exactly the same ring as the
character matrix but just with
different variables called h sub f's
for each non-empty flat f with some
relations
and it's defined by setting
h sub f equals the sum
of all minus z sub g where g is all the
flats containing
the given f so this is
literally a linear change of coordinates
from the original
variables defining the charring of a
metroid
to just new set of variables that we're
calling h sub f's
it turns out if you order the flats by
rank
there's a upper triangular change of
coordinates that's all there is
and a priori this is unclear what this
should or
what this would even achieve right it's
just linear change of coordinates
but turns out it does quite a few things
so let me tell you what the first key
property of doing this change of
coordinates is sorry so include the
whole uh
ground set as well right the whole
that's right
yeah so for those who
are familiar with the work in ahk they
have a slightly different presentation
of the chow ring where they do not
include
the ground set and that can be a small
source of
um confusion here
so if you want to translate that to ahk
c sub f equals in their notation
x of f for
every non full ground set
so those are all the same and
the one that corresponds to the ground
set
this is in their paper what they're
calling minus of alpha in their paper
so it's almost like exactly the same
presentation but
yeah slightly different and these are
in the f uh the h sub
f's will be neff in the original
presentation either in this slightly
different one i'm
showing you today or in ahk those
variables are far from that
but these steps of f's will be nice and
can you keep the intuition about the
minus sign
ah so i mean it seems to me it should be
positive i mean
that's right yeah so
uh there are a few ways to justify the
minus sign
um one reason is
this kind of annoying thing about
the min versus max convention um
[Music]
here i think the most
natural way to justify it would be
through geometry really which is that
minus z sub e in the presentation
this corresponds to geometrically the
hyperplane class pullback and
what one is trying to do is i want to
restrict where this hyperplane
can be and in the language of object
geometry by subtracting from
this minus e the hyperplane class some
summation of more c sub f's where f is
not
ground sense so anything this will look
something like this
by subtracting that part i'm requiring
this hyperplane
to be on certain subspaces so
let me get to that um in a moment it
will be one of the first key properties
are there any other questions before i
move on i haven't really
fully answered the most recent question
but i'll do so
in a little bit but any other questions
okay so let's get to the first key
property
and is that these variables called h sub
f's
correspond to a pretty well studied
operation in matrix theory known as
principal truncations
or in this case corresponding to f
is a principal truncation of m by f
so this is an operation that outputs a
new metroid on the same ground set
from the old um for
according to any given flat f now let me
do it
in an example from the one before
also meanwhile answering the question
that was raised earlier
so the variable
c minus z sub e the whole ground set
represents um in a fairly precise sense
a general hyperplane in this hyperplane
arrangement
now if i'm looking at h
sub let's say 0 1 this
is minus c of the whole ground set
see 0 to 3. minus
zero one now
what subtracting this part does is that
now
in a precise geometric sense called
you look at the sections of the
line bundle defined by this divisor if
one is
to be precise but basically the punch
line is that
now we're looking at a general
hyperplane
that must pass through the subspace
corresponding to your flat zero one
so the in this case the flat 0 1
corresponding
corresponds to this point and
the variable h sub zero one represents a
general hyperplane
that contains that point zero one
that's drawn in green
and now let's intersect the original
hyperplanes
0 1 2 and 3 and see how that intersects
with this
green one and that gives us a new
hyperplane arrangement
drawn here
so the we get a new matrix coming from
this new hyperplane arrangement
drawn on this green line
and the flats look like this now
so i've done this as like a kind of
looking at the geometry of hyperplane
arrangement but in general one can
perform this principle truncation as
follows so
i'm given a flat in this example zero
one
look at everything above it let's circle
that in the
whole set of flats that i've drawn
and kill everything that's directly
below
anything in this green bubble so kills
this one
this this this
and then move this bubble down one step
and then you will see that once you do
that
um ah it also kills one because one is
directly below zero one
so once you move this bubble down one
you'll see that the resulting thing
is exactly the lattice of flats
that i've drawn here so that's the
operation of principal truncation
and it's fairly well studied in the
theory of metroids
and that's the first key property that
these variables have
that now in the old case each variable
has it does have a
interpretation combinatorially but it's
a little harder to use
especially when i'm trying to take
consider monomials
in the variables so first we have
interpretation of these variables in
terms of these
combinatorial operations called
principal truncations
one can upgrade this to
monomials in h sub fs in fact
what we can show is that there is a
monomial basis
for the char ring in these
variables h of f's and they correspond
to
combinatorial structures that we call
relative sugar major so this is not too
important for this talk
but the point is that we can understand
the ring quite well combinatorially
by exploiting this idea that each
variable corresponds to a principal
truncation now
and in fact with this knowledge
again this is a little more side remark
for today's talk but one can recover
poincare duality
with pretty much no induction so
just straight up point guard reality we
understand the basis
of this character right now and with
that point guard duality is
not that hard to prove so already it's
showing some
showing some promise that these
variables are
really nice to look at any questions
at this point
so this principle truncation is always a
matrix right
yes so it's a metroid that one obtains
by doing this process
that i just did in an example on there's
like a basis description of it circuit
description
like written down in oxley's book or
brillowski's
chapter in uh neil white's anthology
so combinatorially well studied
thankfully
any other questions
okay so what's the second key property
so this is the part where one can really
witness
or get a hint of h of f snappness
so more precisely let me tell you
what's going on here
so what poincare duality for this
charting of a mate choice says is that
we have a
nice isomorphism map from the top
non-vanishing degree part of the chao
ray
to r just like homology so let's call
that
integral m just like the chromology
rings
of smooth manifolds
and we want to compute the following
or look at the following polynomial
which i'll call the volume polynomial
abbreviated vp
and it will have formal variables in z
sub x
where f's are non-zero flats or
non-empty flats
it's defined as follows
so again take formal linear combination
over all non-empty flats
x sub f h sub f
raise it to the power of d so
this is an element in the degree one
part
with just formal variables x of x and
then i raise it to power of d
and now i'm applying this degree map to
the whole thing
so this is a polynomial
the exodus
and one hopes
that this is florencia
so if we go back to
this classical geometric theorem
if these elements in the degree one part
of the charring have some property
called
naf then this volume polynomial
is laurentian so that's the classical
fact
and in fact the hajj riemann relations
is basically almost an equivalent
statement
to that fact but we want to prove that
this polynomial that i just
wrote down is laurentian without
appealing to the works of adiposito and
cats
and we're trying to give a simpler proof
of it so we shouldn't rely upon that
so can we show that this is florencian
just straight off
looking at the definition of laurentian
polynomials
and thankfully the answer is yes uh in
fact it turns out
computing this has some very nice
combinatorial structure
which i'll tell you about now
so what's the main statement
well to compute this polynomial
i need to be able to compute
what the product of h sub fs are
for
any multi set of d flats
i need to know how these degree d
monomials evaluate under this
uh degree map d is the right or d plus
one is the rank
so d plus one is the rank um
but the top non-vanishing degree part of
the chao ring lives in
deep degree so there's like a minus one
so you can think of this phenomena as
the
subspace we're looking at is d plus one
dimensional but since we're working all
projectively it's dimension d
so i want to be able to compute this for
any
d many flats where in this list of
course some flats can be repeated
so any degree d monomials in h sub f
i want to know how they evaluate to
under this degree map
and that's the theorem that i'll
write down right here
and first off right off the bat
something nice is that the value is
always
always either one or zero which is
almost miraculous
but if you're thinking geometrically
this is like
how it should be since we're looking at
intersection hyperplanes
so it's always one or zero and it's one
and exactly
if it satisfies the following
so i look at the union
of flats
for everything in some subset j of d
the rank of that should be greater than
size of j
plus one where j ranges over all
non-empty
subset of 1 through d
so pick any subset j
of the flats in the list here
f1 through d repeats aloud
look at the union of those look at its
rank
and has to be greater than the size of j
plus one
and if that's satisfied for every subset
i can pick j
then the value is one here
it's zero otherwise
now for especially combinatorially
minded in the audience
you'll probably look at this and think
oh that looks awfully familiar
so instead of rank of the subset of a
matrix if i had
the size of the subsets so not rank
and that looks awfully like the
hall's marriage condition why can there
be matching
except there's this plus one
and your hunch is actually right so this
includes a matching problem
and i'll just kind of tell you a brief
story of what this matching problem
is so i have some
bipartite graph and there's a matching
problem
and without this plus one
so let's say there's no plus one right
now if it's just
size of j and then no rank sign here but
the size of the
union then that's exactly
hall's marriage problem now with this
plus one added
this is what alex posnikov and his paper
dihedral association beyond calls
the dragon marriage problem
so the story is that well here's a
matching between jews and dudettes
and now
for the dragon matching problem a dragon
will randomly come by
and take a random dude away
it's unfortunate um but the question is
can there still be matching and
um this condition is saying if it meets
the condition with this plus one
um it says that yes there can still be a
match
and finally getting rid of
these absolute value signs or the
cardinality signs and replacing that
by rank i was subsetting a metroid
this is the what one can think of as
rado's generalization of hal's theorem
so the matching should satisfy a certain
independence condition
coming from matrix and we call this the
dragon
hall radio condition
so we can understand these intersection
numbers
these values of applying the degree map
to any monomial in the h is very very
well
like it has nice description
it's either one or zero which is great
and also
we know exactly when it's won by this
matching problem
let me make a brief remark
evaluating the same thing but with
disease of variables
the original presentation
uh this is pretty complicated like
first of all it's not always one or zero
and also it's
not even always not negative it can be
very negative these coefficients
uh complicated
and giving a formula for this was
actually my first paper
so now let's get to showing that
our volume polynomial vp
of x's is laurentian
so to show that this polynomial that we
defined
in the previous slide as follows
to show that this is laurentian sorry
please go on yeah
good question the monomial you have for
h
is is not multi-linear right
you can't have repetition yes
yeah the repetition is absolutely
allowed and in fact
that's what makes the fact that
repetition of
the f one dot f d like there can be same
flats in that list
repetition is what makes this
computation really quite difficult if
there's no repetition the competition is
quite easy
but yeah repetition is absolutely
allowed so for any monomial
not necessarily square free we're trying
to evaluate this
and turns out with this h variables the
values are
quite simple one or zero and we know
exactly when it's one
ah and i think i forgot to mention um
this actually generalizes
postnatals
um theorem on the volumes of generalized
permutation
so of course it's an independent proof
and by setting the metroid to be the
boolean metroid
in other words every subset is
independent one recovers
pros and cons result
okay so now i want to show that this
volume polynomial solution
and well
to do so we need to understand the
support very well and we do
this thing tells you what the support of
this volume polynomial is
because when i'm computing this well i
just expand this out
i have a bunch of monomials in the h
steps multiplied to monomials and xf's
and i know which ones are zero and which
ones are not
so that's great so i know the support
pretty
well through this theorem and it turns
out the support
well first of all is a polymetroid
and has a quite a rich structure that i
think
will be worth exploring in fact
within the support of this volume
polynomial
if you look at square free part
consisting of rank two flats
it contains in it to do what's known as
dil word truncation of a matrix so i
won't get too much into this
but seems like outside of just trying to
show that this volume polynomial has
quite a nice combinatorial properties
just looking at the support now what
about the partial derivatives
so say i want to take a partial
derivative
by some variable x of f corresponding to
a flat f
of this following polynomial
and from our first key property
this is more or less equal up to like
few binomial coefficients and
like such that so basically equal to
the volume polynomial or the principal
truncation
of that matrix by f so it just knocks it
rank one down by one and it's a smaller
choice
on the same ground set so if i were to
do this
d minus two many times
this gets me a volume polynomial of a
rank
3 metroid so chris
yes isn't this just the
generating polynomial for the polymetric
so i think you don't need to
differentiate
so it follows follows except from this
dragon condition that it is a polymetric
and and what you have here is just the
generating exponential generating
polynomial for the
uh for this polymetroid
ah um let's see
but you can do it this way too but but
yeah okay i guess yeah
shortcut yeah i guess that's correct
yeah maybe easier to understand
yeah so in either way
the point is that we can understand the
partials very well and get down to just
another rank three matrix
so we understand the partial derivatives
pretty well
and rank three matrix are fairly easy to
deal with
so with those two in mind it's once one
observes these two things it's
it's like not too difficult to show that
this polynomial that we wanted to show
to be laurentian is laurentian
it's quite nice
so we conclude that this point
polynomial
is orange
so i'm pretty much out of time
and this is what this says is that
this polynomial is once again log
concave and the positive orthant
in other words in the induction scheme
it provides a key step
so in the heart the year of metroids
that's laid out by the protector ohio
cats
among the hardest parts is to show that
the hot riemann relations is satisfied
for some
ample element and
that's the part where they really need
this kind of nested induction within a
matter
but in this approach using these
variables
h sub fs well first we could prove the
point card duality without any induction
and now borrowing this powerful tool
laurenian polynomials are strongly
concave polynomials
by showing that this volume polynomial
is florencian we can
show that kind of really difficult
induction step where we have to show
that
at least one there is at least one ample
element
satisfying hot human relation without
doing this nested induction just an
induction on rank now
so that's how this plays a role in that
so with that um i'll end my talk here
yeah thanks for a really beautiful talk
uh any
any questions
so i guess one question is can you get
the higher hot dream on relations
directly from this or you have to do the
induction
ah so that's a great question and the
answer is unfortunately no
it is a big mystery to what extent
laurentian polynomials include any of
the
higher hot treatment relations i think
in fact so far we don't actually even
know any
combinatorial applications of higher
degree hot human relations
not just in the context of materials but
also in like the context of simple
polytubes and so forth
yeah i think there's there are almost no
applications of them
anywhere except for one application so
yeah yeah so it's that that's a big
mystery
so maybe so when you
[Music]
when you want to close the prove the log
concavity of the say the
characteristic polynomial or the the one
divided by
t minus one then you you actually need
to to do some
you need some elements to be in in the
in the nephron right
so is there some do you see any and
there you you need to
sort of rely on some of the uh
theory of adiprasito and patel
so can you is there some way you see
using your machinery that you can go
around this
so let's see
so there the nav elements
so the alpha and beta they call it the
alpha part is fairly easy to understand
but then the beta part is the tricky one
and the way i interpret their work
is that
so by showing hot human relations
for sort of the biggest amplicone one
can imagine
that's like the hard part
and to do that one they had to do this
whole induction to prove hatchimal
relations
and in general i think by showing that
if one has some sort of an induction
scheme um
which usually exists um either
like for example in macmillan's simple
polytrophs case or in this case
if one can show that certain polynomial
is
lorentzian with respect to a very
carefully chosen
set of neff elements so here
the beta 1 is actually not a positive
linear combination of h sub x
so if i look at the positive cone of
these h's of f's it's not the full
ample cone so that's an important
thing to keep in mind
but in any case by showing that this is
florencian
one can provide a key step in the
induction and then
extend the the
domain of ample cone for which riemann
hot treatment relation holds to
the full thing where we need it to be
for example in the characteristic point
on
our case so that's the scheme
yeah i mean now you have a
well your expression of the volume
polynomial in your new
variables is are is very beautiful and
simple
so maybe there's hope for that
you can sort of get a fully
combinatorial proof of
the whole thing but
maybe that's too much to look for
um for all the hot streaming relations
or
no so that you so you still
still have to rely on some theory of the
original paper but
maybe there's a sort of
a pure combinatorial proof
that you can get from your yeah
that may be possible yeah maybe we don't
have to do this induction scheme at all
just yeah but um
yeah that's unclear to me at the moment
yeah i think the question is beta as you
say is not a positive combination of
this ace
that's right uh you basically use the
fact that this
ample cone is convex and you know
there's a uh you know
real complex analysis part going on
right you want to say that you don't
make the eigen value
zero then you go from yeah cone to the
beta
let's try
yeah you're still using as far as i
remember they had this fact that
if one if it is hot dream on for one
point in the apple cone it's
ultra mud for everything right so you're
still using that
yeah that's right so that there's not
too hard to prove
yeah um that's like the key idea
like we just gotta show it for one of
them so why not show it for
one of them in this very kind of special
sub cone of the full amplicone
spanned by the positives of the h sub fs
yeah that's exactly right